what is going on everybody welcome to
part eight of the neural networks from
scratch videos
in the previous video we learned how to
calculate the categorical cross
entropy as our metric for loss and in
this video what we want to talk about
is how to incorporate that into our sort
of overall
neural network framework that we've been
building in this series
so when we go to apply it there's a few
changes that we need to make we need to
make it a little bit more dynamic
as well as address one of the hurdles
that you're going to find
when you could actually run this so
let's get to it up to this point with
calculating loss we've only considered
calculating this categorical cross
entropy from the softmax output of a
single sample at a time but in reality
we'll be feeding in multiple samples at
a time or a batch of data
which will return to us a batch of
softmax outputs
from here we'd also have a batch of
targets so let's imagine our three
classes are dog
cat or human let's first consider a
scenario where our targets are sparse as
opposed to where our targets are one hot
encoded
so imagine that our batch of targets are
that the first sample is a dog the
second sample is a cat
and the third sample is a cat that would
mean then that the dog class
represented as a single sparse value
would just be a zero
the cat target would be represented as a
one and the final cat target for that
third sample would also be a one
so this would be our sparse target
vector for the softmax outputs
so to visualize how they line up that
first value corresponds to the first
sample softmax outputs
and the zero means that the target class
was zero
so to get the confidences for this class
we just grabbed the value at the index
of 0
of the first of the softmax outputs
which is a 0.7
for the second value in the class target
vector we have a class of 1. so we would
be interested in the confidence of the
element at the index of 1 for the second
softmax output vector this is a 0.5 in
this case
and then finally for the third sample in
that batch the target was a 1
so we would again match that to the
softmax output confidence of 0.9
in that third sequence now that we know
how these targets line up to the
confidence values that we're interested
in how might we program this in pure
python so one way might just be to zip
these two lists together then iterate
the target index and the softmax
distribution where the desired
confidence value would be the value at
the
index of the target index in that
softmax
distribution that said we're going to
incorporate numpy now which is faster
and more concisely implemented
so we can actually get rid of the
zipping and iteration and instead we can
do
all of this exact same thing in one line
since the softmax outputs is now a numpy
array
with numpy array properties and the
output will now be
a vector so what's happening in this
last line might be
a little confusing or hazy for some of
you
so let's talk about it for a moment so
because softmax outputs is now a numpy
array
we can actually index this numpy array
in a variety of ways thanks to numpy
so the way that we're doing it here is
we can actually pass lists of
indices that we are interested in and
then it's by dimension so this will be
at the you know first dimension what are
the indices that we're interested in and
then the second dimension what are the
indices that we're interested in
so the zero one two this is your zero
this is your one this is your two and
then class targets is right here
zero one one so again that's going to be
zero here
and then 1 1. so
if that's kind of confusing to you i
would suggest maybe just kind of tinker
around with this so for example if we
replace class targets with just 0 0 0
it's going to take the zeroth element um
from each of these so 0.7
1 and then 0.02
but in our case we're going to use class
targets because that's these are the
values that we're actually interested in
so
it becomes just a really nice concise
way
to get at the exact values that we're
interested in
in one clean line now rather than hard
coding the range of however long our
values are we can actually just use the
python range of the length
of the softmax outputs
and as we learned in the previous video
categorical cross-entropy in the case of
classification with neural networks
simplifies to being
the negative log of the target class's
confidence so we just wrap this in a
negative np.log
the resulting values being our losses
from here we calculate the loss for this
batch as just the mean
of the losses and then with that you
might be thinking
hey we're done right and you'd be wrong
because we're eventually going to hit a
problem with this and that problem
is zero the negative log of zero is
infinite so we have a slight issue
now if the confidence for the correct
class
is a zero i suppose you could argue well
it is infinitely wrong
but it's kind of a problem for us so if
for example
if we wrap this in negative np dot
log and we check our results right
everything's looking
pretty good you get a higher loss if the
the further away you are um so for
example if we decrease this to 0.2 we
can see the loss
definitely increased to that 1.6 but if
we make it a 0.0
we do get a warning it does still run
but we see
that the loss is actually infinite
um and this wouldn't necessarily
be the end of the world because that's
still it's not not necessarily wrong
but the problem is when we go to wrap
this in a
numpy dot mean so as soon as you throw
in one
infinity everything just
dies out because now the the average
the batch loss is also infinite so just
one time you get a zero and it's it's
game over for you
one option that we have to handle for
this is to clip
the values in the range by some fairly
insignificant amount so for example
one e negative seven and then we're no
longer dealing with infinity
and we want a clip because we don't just
simply want to shave off
from the low end of a confidence uh and
cause some sort of bias so we're
actually going to clip
one e negative seven from zero so we'll
start the range at one e negative seven
all the way up to one minus one e
negative seven
thus we will just simply clip all of
these predicted values with numpy.clip
to ensure that we don't wind up with
this infinity problem
so we'll start by defining a
common loss class so we'll call this
class
loss and in this loss class we're going
to have a define
calculate and the calculate is going to
take
self it will take output and y so output
is the output from the model
y is the intended target values
inside the calculate what we want to do
is we want to get those sample
losses so we're going to say sample
losses equals
self dot forward and the forward method
here will pass output and y
so the forward method is going to vary
depending
on which type of loss you are actually
using
so that will vary but all of the losses
are going to need to calculate loss so
they will share this kind of calculate
method here
so that's our sample losses then we want
to again that will be like a vector of
values so what we want to do now is
data loss or batch loss is going to be
the
numpy mean of the sample losses
and then finally we will just simply
return
the data loss so in this case
we want to define the forward method for
at least
one loss function that we intend to use
which is going to be categorical cross
entropy
so just below this class we'll define
another class and we will
turn the page of our book and this is
going to be called
claw clause class
loss underscore categorical cross and
trophy
this is going to inherit from the base
loss class now we just need to define
our forward method that will take self
and then y prediction and
y true so again why pred these are going
to be the values from the
neural network why true these are the
target training values
so uh first thing we're going to do is
we need to know what is the
total length so we're going to say
samples equals len
of really arguably whoops arguably
either of those but we will go with
y pred now what we want to do is
clip these values so y print
clipped is equal to numpy dot clip
and we want to clip the y prediction to
be
between 1 e negative 7
so a number close to zero but not quite
zero for infinity purposes
and then to be not biased we're going to
do
one minus one e negative seven
so uh once we've got the clip done the
next thing that we need to consider
is sometimes people will pass targets
that are
either in the form of scalar values so
class one class zero class one class one
or it will be one hot encoded so it
might be
um zero one uh well let's make it the
same as it was above so
um no i had it right
anyway uh and then one zero and just to
save myself from typing out the rest i'm
gonna say like this
so in this case you've got two samples
but they were just scalar values in this
case you've got two samples but they're
one hot encoded values
so we want to be able to handle for both
of these because it's pretty common
practice that people will use
one or either it's not really any one
that is
more common than the other people are
kind of comfy using using both so you
want to be able to handle
uh for whether someone has passed one or
the other so the way that we can find
out
which one has been passed is we can just
do if len
of a y true
y true dot shape is
equal to one this means they have passed
uh scalar values so not one hot encoded
values
just true scalar class values so in this
case we're going to say correct
confidences equals
y pre-clipped
and then we're going to say range
of samples and then
why true so let's solidify what's
happening here in the correct
confidences
in the case where the targets are a
scalar form so the target's array
is just a one dimensional array so first
you have the y
pre clipped values and we're indexing
those by the range of however many
samples we have in the batch which
really just means we want to reference
all of the samples in the batch along
the
second dimension of the batch's clipped
outputs we want to grab the index of the
y true value
so this means from the zeroth sample we
grab the zero with value
from the first sample we grab the first
sith value
and then from that final sample index of
two we grab that first if element again
then we'll come down and then handle for
the other possibility here which would
be l
or well where's in the book we're saying
l if but
i guess we'll see we'll handle it with
an if l if len
y true dot shape
uh double equals two so in this case it
would be
a one hot encoded vectors that are being
passed here
if that's true what we want to say is
correct underscore confidences
is equal to np dot sum
of y pre-clipped
times y true
um and that sum operation is happening
on
axes equals one
spot check make sure i uh didn't screw
that up i think so
cool so in the second case the targets
why true
is a two-dimensional array because it's
an array of one-hot encoded vectors
so the length of y true.shape is two
in this case we're going to do a sum of
the clipped values multiplied by the y
true array which is that array of the
one hot encoded vectors and we're doing
the sum
along axes one so what's what ends up
happening is we're multiplying each of
those vectors
and so when we do that we're multiplying
each individual element at the same
index
in one vector with the other vector and
so what's happening here is everything
winds up getting multiplied by zero
except for the target class's confidence
because in the one hot encoded
vector everything's a zero except for
the the target class
so summing all these together along axes
one is giving us just those values that
we want
so these are the two methods that we
have for dynamically handling either one
hot encoded vectors or scalar class
values it doesn't matter which
ends up being passed here either one
will work so that's how we can handle
for the correct confidences
and then all we want to do from this
point is to do negative
log likelihoods
is equal to the negative np dot log
of correct confidences
and then we return the negative log
likelihood so once we've gotten to this
point
these negative log likelihoods is going
to be again the vector of values
that comes from to here to sample losses
we take the mean we return
that data loss that batch loss so now
what we'll do
is using what we've just coded we'll
define
our loss function as the loss
categorical cross entropy object we will
then
calculate our actual loss by saying loss
function dot
calculate and in here again we pass the
y
prediction versus the target so the y
prediction will be whatever your final
output layer was that used that soft max
activation in our case that's activation
two
so basically the output is going to be
activation two
dot output and then our target was y
because that just comes from all the way
up here
so this gives us our actual loss value
and we can even print that out
print loss colon
and then loss we'll save that run that
and sure enough we get a loss of
1.0986104
which does indeed match the book
so briefly we'd like to show a way to
calculate accuracy since you'd likely be
calculating accuracy in your code around
this step but we'll probably
revisit accuracy later so given your
targets and your softmax outputs you can
actually calculate
accuracy from here pretty easily you can
run the outputs
through a numpy.arcmax calculation which
will return the index value for
whichever value
is the greatest you can run this np.org
max on the entirety of the softmax
outputs
by utilizing the axis perimeter which
notifies numpy
of which axes you actually want this
calculated on
and that would be one in this case since
it's a batch of these outputs
so you can then say predictions is equal
to the arg max
of axes one of the softmax outputs
then we're just going to compare these
two and wherever the values are
equal we have a true or a one a match if
not then it's a zero we got it wrong
and then we would just sum up the
average of this so this means that the
accuracy is going to be the mean of the
equivalence check
of these predictions which were just
argmax outputs from each sample
output and the class targets
so while accuracy is practical and
useful
the metric that we are most interested
in when training a neural network is
actually the
loss metric since it is a metric of how
wrong
something is and our goal is to
decrease that loss now how do we
decrease that loss well we know that we
can
adjust the weights and biases of a
neural network
but how do we do that so the
optimization of weights and biases is
the subject of the next and likely next
few videos so stay tuned for those
again if you are interested in this and
want it in physical form
you can get the neural networks from
scratch book you can get that at nnfs.i
oh otherwise
i will see you guys in the next video
you